in general the practice of promising
donations to charities or to people or
to causes and not actually following
through on those donations that is very
low immoral activity it's even worse
when you make promises publicly that
you're going to make contributions to a
charity or to a person or whoever for
political gain and then never make the
donations and Donald Trump has done that
many times we've been covering it for
months but there is a new low that is
being reported by the Washington Post
which is that Donald Trump offered a
grieving military father $25,000 and
never sent him the money I'm talking
about the father of 22 year old army
sergeant Dylan Baldrige Dylan Baldrige
and two other soldiers were killed by an
Afghan police officer and an attack on
June 10th that is more than four months
ago Dylan's father is Chris Baldrige and
he received a call from Donald Trump
some time ago that by all accounts
lasted about 15 minutes and during that
call Donald Trump did something that is
sort of odd for a president to do he
offered Chris Baldrige $25,000 and
promised that he would have his staff
create a fund raiser for the Baldrige
family and according to the Washington
Post's reporting this month Chris
Baldrige said about his conversation
with Donald Trump quote he said I'm
going to write you a check out of my
personal account for $25,000 and I was
just floored I could not believe he was
saying that and I wish I had it recorded
because the man did say this he said no
other president has ever done something
like this but he said I'm going to do it
unfortunately neither happened Donald
Trump never sent the money as of
yesterday the fundraiser for the family
was never set up as of yesterday
absolutely and totally disgusting
Trump's reaction hey see I do call some
parents of dead soldiers no I'm kidding
Trump's reaction the White House
reaction was actually to issue a
statement saying the check has been sent
literally the reaction is the
is in the mail serious question if this
death took place in June and Trump spoke
to Chris Baldrige not long after that if
the check has only been sent out on
October 18th which was yesterday after
it goes public that Chris Baldrige never
received the check do any of us really
believe that the check would have been
sent were it not for the negative
reporting and you see this completely
impossible juxtaposition where on one
hand you have Trump and his
administration saying it's bogus
it's a fabricated story of course we
sent him the money and the check is in
the mail now more than four months later
what a big coincidence that the check
was sent out only right when that year
the Washington Post started doing
critical reporting about this and I
actually think that this is a really
dumb move from Trump because if Trump
does follow through and cut a check to
talk for 25 grand to a gold star dad it
appears as though he is the unempioyed
just pay people off when they're
grieving if he actually did this because
he does if he did this and he doesn't
send the check then he seems to be the
liar who lies about contributions and
donations which we also know him to be
that's the problem with this it seems
like a really stupid move for Donald
Trump and you know he wants to further
the narrative that he's really good with
these families that he's calling the
narrative the the the the family is in
creating this narrative that he's this
empathetic guy which we all know he
isn't the Washington Post
actually interviewed families of 13 of
the 20-plus service members that have
been killed since Donald Trump has
assumed the presidency half had received
phone calls and the other half had not
one widow was reportedly asked to wait
by the phone by the White House and
expect a call from Donald Trump and
Donald Trump never called what do you
believe do you believe the grieving
military father who has spent his entire
life
rather do you believe the grieving
military father who says that he was
promised the donation and didn't get it
or do you believe Trump who has a long
track record of promising donations and
never making them I know who I believe I
believe the grieving military father not
Donald Trump send me your thoughts about
this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show we'll
take a break and be back with plenty
more right after this
today's program is made possible in part
by Blue Sky binaries blockchain Academy
blockchain the technology on which
Bitcoin and crypto currencies can be
based many people not aware of both the
power and the risks that are carried by
blockchain technology I've only started
to get into this a little bit buying a
little bit of Bitcoin here and their
dollar cost averaging but a lot of
people myself included believe that
blockchain technology is just too
complicated to understand but the truth
is it doesn't have to be that way the
blue sky binary blockchain Academy from
leading financial education firm blue
sky binary explains how blockchain works
and it can work in addition to existing
knowledge that you have about blockchain
it's for both beginners and active
cryptocurrency users alike with the
course students are taken through a
series of topics which ultimately will
deliver a very solid understanding of
how blockchain works and help students
realize the potential future uses of
blockchain technology we've talked about
this in the pharmaceutical world we've
talked about this in the IT security
world many many possibilities for
blockchain and the course includes video
on-demand online tests access to a
community of traders and blockchain
enthusiasts and at blue sky binary.com /
David you can register to get a free
three-day trial which includes access to
the first module of the course for you
to evaluate the overall quality and
decide if you want to stick with it get
a free three-day trial at blue sky
binary.com / David